Now, I'd like to
introduce you to today's presenters.
Professor Bob Sutton, Hayagreeva Rao, and John Lilly.
John Lilly is a partner at Greylock,
as well as on the board of directors of Crew, Figma,
Angle Technologies, Caffeine, Code for America, and more.
John is also the former CEO of Mozilla and a Stanford University alum.
He's also a co-teacher in the Graduate School of Business,
People Operations course with Huggy Rao.
Also, we have Bob Sutton who is
a Professor of Management Science and Engineering in the Stanford School of
Engineering and a Professor- and Professor Huggy Rao
is Professor of Organizational Behavior at the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Together they have written a book titled Scaling Up Excellence,
hosted a podcast titled Friction on Organization and Culture,
and are academic directors of
our Online Professional Education Program
Stanford Innovation Entrepreneurship Certificate.
Now, that we've welcomed them, I will turn it over to them.
Great. Thank you so very much Annette.
It's, uh, [NOISE] delight to be here this
morning with John in the one hand and Bob on the other.
And our plan is to actually have a conversation and
maybe take questions in the last ten minutes or so. Is that right, Annette?
Yes.
Wonderful. So, let's actually begin with John right away.
Wh- why the word people operations?
Why not HR?
Why not personnel?
[inaudible]. Yeah. You know,
I'm not sure if you coined the term.
I think, my guess, is that it- it is very public,
Google, uh, [inaudible] people outside Google calls it this.
And, I think, it was intentional to- to reframe that's everybody who worked there.
And, I think, the H- HR,
you know, human resources, human capital,
other things that we call these things for- for years and they have a- [NOISE] they
have a bit of a fixed- a fixed, um, [NOISE] sensibility.
I think, what people ops is a sensitive- people operations,
you're trying to make a- make a system that runs over time.
And, I think, that somebody has feedback leaves,
and changes, and evolves over time.
That's- that's my sense of why- of why that turns evolve.
I've always like it because it's more active,
ac- active than an asset [NOISE] resources, [NOISE] capital.
So, when you are actually looking at startups,
[NOISE] what do you particularly pay attention to when you think of People Operations?
Yeah. Well, I think, we- we talked about this- you talk about this
a lot in our class in business school that it really depends on the stage of company.
So, a lot of times people come to us in the business school and they talk about hiring,
they say- and they think of hiring as well.
I- I get my resumes from my HR department,
and I picked the best resumes I like,
and I even talk to these person [NOISE] [inaudible] And first from- what we found for
startups for even for bigger companies like Mozilla where
there is that the best- the best candidate [inaudible] forward.
[NOISE] It's an act,
it's like, again, like the word people out to self.
It's an active, [NOISE] active orientation which is recruiting.
So, it's like how do you even get people to know about the company?
How do you get people to care?
How do you get people to come? And it's a- it's
a two-way conversation rather than sitting back and evaluating.
Uh, so, yes. [inaudible].
I- I- I have a [NOISE] question related to that.
Um, is- is it your experience it's better to hire people who have worked
together before and to have them recruit one
another rather than just aggregating the best,
but to actually bringing people who have some experience together?
Yeah. So, I think, this is a tricky and long discussion.
I think that it sort of, uh,
if you- if you just play it out.
Like, if you hire people that you know then,
you'll tend to be very homogeneous.
[NOISE] Who look like you,
have the same background as you that kind of stuff.
There's- there's an old African proverb, like,
if you want to go- if you want to go fast, go alone.
If I want to go far, go together.
I think, that is like- as it start to scale up, I- I think,
and when you- and when you're starting you have to have
some shared background because- this just- the demands are too high.
[NOISE] You've got three, or four,
or ten people all trying to do things.
And if you don't have a shared background there's
no- then you have to figure everything out from first principle.
So, you know, I think,
it helps to have people who have worked together, who know each other.
I think, in a limit though you get a big company,
then you want to be diverse because, I think,-
Right.
-diverse will give you more robust ideas, more strength.
And so, the question is like- so, I think,
we know that when you start,
your going to be a little homogenous.
[NOISE] [inaudible] when you sustain,
you want to be a little diverse.
So, the question is, how do we translate that?
So, that's it. And as we know, including from, um,
you know, our colleague Kathy Eisenhardt there's, um,
evidence that shows when people have- have worked together
before that for startups are more likely to be successful.
Yeah.
Since we're sitting on the Stanford campus right now,
Hewlett and Packard are the famous example.
They did classes together and they figured out they could work together.
And hence, what was a once great technology company was formed by them.
[NOISE] Uh, but, the diversity of things' interesting.
So, uh, there's an argument then,
you should have diverse funds early and you've got both for life. [NOISE]
Yeah. [LAUGHTER]. Yeah. I think,
the question- it- it's more about diversity of,
I think, it's like diverse pathways of thought. Is that what you really want?
Yeah. [NOISE] [OVERLAPPING].
Diversity which often is related to diversity in background.
[NOISE] And so, I think, the question is more like
if you start the core whose work together,
[NOISE] I thinks, it's much more likely to succeed and you
can look at almost any startup.
It starts with a core of people who know each other.
Right.
Uh, [inaudible] sort of trust.
It's very hard to trust people who don't come from some shared background.
But, then the question is like within ten, the first ten people,
the first 20 people, the first 50 people,
how do you become, how do you build more and more new diversity, yet?
[NOISE] Yeah. There's a lot of companies that will start and- and,
yeah, unfortunately, would be the first five people will be men.
Right.
And then, they'll hire their friends or I'm sure the next 15 people will be men.
And- and the next thing you know you got the 20% of the company is all dudes.
It's like how do you hire the first female into that group, like good luck.
And so, um, there're other companies like,
you know, Bret Taylor everyone here,
[inaudible] and they- they recruited for diversity from [NOISE] nearly the beginning.
Right.
And as a result, they had something like 40% women on the engineering team,
uh, when they were getting to scale up [inaudible] or so.
I think, it's tricky.
I think, but, I think, if you- I
think you'd have to be a little homogenous when you start.
You have to be a little homogenous.
So, for our readers,
we- I just want to draw your attention to that wheel on the slide there,
that we like, actually,
represents the framework of what John and I along with Sue J. Jasper,
we use it in the course on People Operations Startup to Scale-up.
It's actually built around an acronym called F.A.R.T.H.E.R.
John accuses me of liking acronyms and I plead guilty to the charge.
So, the acronym F.A.R.T.H.E.R.
stand- the F stands for finding people,
the A is for aligning them,
the R is for real-time feedback,
[NOISE] the T is for teaming,
the H is for hacking,
the E is for engaging,
and R is for reinventing,
and at the center is, of course,
the mindset of the organization,
the culture that is there.
Thus far, we've actually been focusing on finding people.
And so, that's where we are.
But, before we move to the other elements, John,
can you give us a sense when you advise startups and you work with them-
You know, what's the ratio of the number of people you meet and the hires you close?
Is it like one higher for every 10 people you meet?
Or is it much more than that?
And is that even a useful diagnostic?
Yeah, that's an interest- I don't know quite how I'd characterize that.
What I would say is that, um,
you think a lot of- you think a lot about pipelines.
So I focus less on the output which is
the number of hires and more on like how do you build process workflow.
So you see enough people and enough diversity in the pipeline.
So well we spent a lot of time,
a lot of time in early starts is like how do we find it and how do
we- how do we- how do we find and evaluate the right people.
And how do we convince them to come and so they think that the pipeline is like we have
to go look through LinkedIn and all the resumes and you had to s- um,
filter that down to calling out like sitting emails.
And like see who responds to you and then doing phone screens.
And then your phone screen and technical screen
and technical screen to, uh, on-site interview.
Onsite interview to which you would get an offer,
to an offer to acceptance.
And we think about like this is a pipeline,
it's like a [OVERLAPPING] pipeline and to you've got
numbers and then you've got conversion ratios in each one.
And so the questions both like how to avoid ho- how to get true positives.
Like how to avoid false positive,
how to avoid false negatives, how to, um,
and we just really focus a lot on the conversions
like the most expensive two parts of tho- of that funnel
are on-site interviews because you bring somebody in they
spent half a day or a day with basically your core team your most important team.
And then which is a very expensive operation.
And then once you find somebody you like them and,
uh, make them an offer you really want to close.
And so the two by conversion numbers I really focused
on are: the number of people who bring onsite,
how many of those do they make an offer to.
And I try to- I try to make sure that, I think- I think,
most startups are probably like a quarter to a third and living outside.
I think that you can build up a more robust,
uh, a better filter than that.
So we try to get closer to half.
And then when you offer to acceptance that's critical and that's a- that's a,
uh, we spend a lot of time being very active and how do you
make the offer you make the offer when they're ready to get it.
Um, you do a lot of things around it to make sure that they're ready to get
the offer and to accept the offer that like you really want to be well over 50 percent.
It's harder now because moving a lot of millenials in particular
gathering up a lot of offers they have five or six to choose from um.
S- so I- I have a question so you're
focusing on how important it is to have a high yield rate.
Um, so I would try to do a yes and another prospective.
And I'm thinking of especially in
the old days at Netflix we've spent a lot of time talking to
crazy Patty McCord about their system and- and Patty described how,
um, a lot of what their goal was was before
people got into interview that they would give them
such a sufficient cultural preview that people would self screen
out so that the people who would agreed to
be interviewed actually would want the job for a good.
Do you- do anything to sort of discourage
the people who won't fit to [OVERLAPPING] take them self out of the pool.
Yeah, I think this is like critical to understand
what organization you're building is and so
Patty famously built this Netflix Culture Deck which was a little self-aggrandizing.
It's a little bit like not exactly right but I think they're trying
to- they're trying to distill their values in such a provocative way.
You'll like would either say, "Oh,
my god I love that," or yup, be repulsed by it.
But no vacation policy, argh.
And, um, so I think-
Either you're a superstar or you're fired.
Yeah. And so I think [LAUGHTER] yeah,
when hiring you're trying to you're trying to elicit its like a- a strong match.
So you're trying to figure out like how do you
build e- especially for startups and early accompany
just kind of figure out how do you build- how you
build an organization with the spikiest people?
Not the best on average but like the spikiest in certain areas.
And so I think the culture deck is a really good thing that she did.
More recently Henry Ward of Eshare's.
So the same kind of thing, like,
here's how we do it, here's how we interview if you don't like it.
And you know I remember,
um, I think the best leaders do this.
So I remember when Steve- I was at Apple, um,
when Steve Jobs came back,
and I think I told you guys this before.
But, um, he gave this big,
uh, speech on time.
And, uh, Apple was I think were trading
for like basically a two billion dollars in
cash and a market cap of Apple was two billion dollars.
We were trading about- had cash and I thought we were going
to get bought by [inaudible] and Steve gave actually look we're going to reinvent the company.
And we're going to- all your all your shares are underwater.
And so we're going to revise your shares.
It's all going to be in the money but they're going to invest for
three years and we're gonna go and we're going to
build amazing products and change the world.
If you don't believe it, get the hell out.
And then what that did it- nobody laughed
about how galvanize the people who wanted to be on [OVERLAPPING].
Wasn't that the same meeting where, uh,
Michael Dell predicted that the company's
got a business and look what was Steve's response- [OVERLAPPING].
I'm not sure I'm allowed to say that. [OVERLAPPING]
So the, um, [OVERLAPPING] eight second bleak [LAUGHTER] like Spike Lee in the Oscars.
[LAUGHTER] The, um, yeah,
Michael Dell in Dell earnings call.
We all remember Dell Computer since it's
so [OVERLAPPING] important because it's actually there's a [inaudible].
The, um, somebody on a dollar in
its costs in which Apple needed the money
and Microsoft AOC severally should give it back.
They shed on the company get back to shareholders.
And right after Steve said that we're going to invest
your options some- someone who had more courage than I do,
um, got up and said,
"Hey went extinct in the queue HSV.
Hey, what do you think about what Michael Dell said about what we should do."
And there is this dead silence.
And ah- and, uh, Steve's like he just just quiet and he said, "F Michael Dell."
He didn't use [OVERLAPPING] he didn't use
that word thing [LAUGHTER] and I'm not self-conscious about it but, um.
But after he said that like everybody in the- in the place where following him.
So- so that's a great- So [inaudible] and I write about,
um, when- when excellence of scale.
You need two things. This is straight from his work on social movements.
You need a hot causing to crank up this collective anger and pride.
And you need to link it to tangible behaviors speed.
[OVERLAPPING] It's the perfect example. Well, he was changing
the options but then he got the motions going to.
So, you know, I want to pick up on
one thing that you just mentioned a little while ago, John.
You used, you used the term match
between the recruited the company in the hiring process.
I'm assuming by that you meant fit.
You know, In other words does the new record fit into the company,
does the company fit with the aspirations of the individual?
Sure.
Do we always hire individuals for fit, what about stretch?
Don't you hire people to stretch the ability of a company to get it to do more?
Do you do those kinds of hires differently or is it the same thing or-?
Yeah, I think- right I think its a critical point.
So I think that when we say the word fed,
often it for, uh,
field called culture fit.
Well, they fit our culture.
Which is, I think,
you guys know that studies but an idea of which is very
often shorthand for this person is like me.
Right [OVERLAPPING] yeah, my favorite person, me.
[LAUGHTER].
[inaudible] tends to reinforce margin A, not gets diversity.
It's, I think, um, when I say
match what you're I think you're trying to do is understand what are
the criteria you're hiring for and does this person match those criteria.
And you're trying to you're trying to pull out the I think you're trying
to as much as you can make- make the criteria explicit.
So you can- you can be somewhat
objective and I think that we're- we're humans we're all biased,
right, biased features, um,
But do you think that- I try not to use words like fit or culture fed this impossible,
so I think it aligns a whole bunch of, like,
a bunch of hidden, uh, ah personal values.
So let me, uh, ah you've seen,
I'm sure, a lot of people and interviewed them.
And I want to focus on the interview part.
I realized of course interviews have dead-on limitations and you have to actually
qualify the prospect as you mentioned in a variety of random ways,
but I'm curious in your interview process,
have you found that useful diagnostic question?
Or have you found something that immediately surfaces as red flags for you?
Yeah. So I think, I probably interviewed
give or take 10 thousand people in my, in my career.
[OVERLAPPING] And probably a couple of those couple of 1000, um,
and I find the more people I
interview the less- the less I believe in my ability to energy.
[NOISE] And what I mean is [OVERLAPPING].
You're not fitting the- the literature,
good for you. [LAUGHTER].
Well, what I meant is that I think there was a time when I was very confident in
my ability to spend 15 minutes for somebody and like half know.
And I think the more people I've interviewed the more I feel like interviews or
these profoundly overloaded contexts where you don't have a shared background,
you don't have shared understanding goal.
It's a very, um, the power dynamic is all messed up.
And so I've come to think of interviews is a very limited specific type of information.
And so I- I think there's- there's things you can learn.
So I think you- I think you can learn whether
if people are somewhat defensive and you can
learn how people react the questions and how to react to stress situation at that.
So he had to say so I think that if you find people
blaming- you heard people talking about their last job and say,
"Oh those guys did this wrong."
Here's all the- they term a lot of blaming.
That's a, that's a clear red flag.
I think the grief that the positives are a little harder.
So I tend to I think we're all different.
Some of people coming with it a roster of questions they'll ask.
I come in and say, "Hey, what are you curious about?
What are you interested in? How are you processing this so far?"
I've tried to, I tried to co-construct knowledge and learning.
But, um, especially if over time at
Greylock has done is talking about the Harper referencing.
So know, you know,
the partner read [inaudible] Hill famously say if I could
do an hour of referencing or an hour interviewing only reference not.
And the point is that, you know,
in an interview you can only get to see- the observed the experience you have during
the time where it's referencing you can talk about months or years of collaboration.
Now, it's still different, like,
human beings don't like saying negative things about
other most [OVERLAPPING] of us human beings [LAUGHTER].
So you've gotta figure out how to elicit, um, uh,
truth from references and that- that's, um,
that's harder to do because you- you- you have to build a strength of
network [inaudible] reputation and-
and- and build the context where people will tell you the truth [OVERLAPPING].
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I won't name the organization,
but there are certain organizations where, uh,
if you get the worst- if it's
a current employee you're really positive references to get rid of them.
[LAUGHTER] So you really got to be careful and that's, uh.
You're the export their products [OVERLAPPING].
They want to export their problems.
Yeah. So it's, yeah. So I think the reason most people think
they're interviewing is useful is because it's,
it's possible to get good at interviewing
yourself whereas you can only get better referencing
when building a network and history [OVERLAPPING] of a time.
Very few people lie to Reid,
the founder of linked-in about a reference because
they know that he knows everyone in the world.
Right. Right.
And it's for that- that's a product of 20 or 30 years or building.
So in other words what referencing is,
is it actually provides,
uh, you know, validation from multiple sources and that's kind of what you want.
I want to go, go, you know, I'm watching the time as well.
So we have this little wheel with the farther framework.
We've been focusing on finding people.
Let's assume there's a startup here,
um, it's gone for- to 25 people.
Sure.
From like five people [NOISE] which of these elements would you think
is the important thing for this startup at 25 to focus on?
Yeah. So I think in a lot of ways the way that wheel works is,
um, is in order.
So you can get find people who have to get him to do things that, uh,
when- when groups are small, uh,
and the you don't have to do a lot of aligning.
So you say, "Hey,
let's go build this product for this consulting services or whatever it
is," and you've got enough shared background that you can kinda just go off and do it,
and you're kind of being your own lanes and you're growing,
and the reason that's powerful is that
everything's happening as fast as they can possibly happens.
It's all happening in your brain.
[NOISE] And the reason you start to get process over times,
like you start to get, uh,
teams and you can't see inside the founder's brain.
And so the founder brain like processes
is- is- is a motion of place of out of the founders [NOISE] and saying,
"Oh, here's a cadence, here are weekly meetings.
Here's the way we build things."
And you're basically trying- to all the constructs out of your-
out of your brain so that other people can contribute.
Right.
And so I would say,
it's 25- by the time it gets to 25 you've got smaller groups.
Right.
And you had to have some process,
and you're trying to figure out like, "Oh,
the groups need to figure out how to work
together," but my experience has been that groups
of three to six people give or take about the right size.
What evidence to support that?
Yeah. I think once you get to seven or eight or nine they become places to hide.
Exactly.
So, so le- this,
this sort of transition from three to six to about 30 person firm or something that
we- we've all been involved a little but wha-
what some of the early processes you think that,
um, are useful and what are the red flags that they're adding
process that makes the cadence destructive friction?
So what do you suggest adding and what do you suggest waiting?
Yeah. I tried to layer in
lightweight ways of committing of the each group committing to each other.
Okay.
So like the- it starts with like weekly commitments or weekly sprints or
maybe I get 25 peoples a
little early for basically talking about quarterly but you're trying to,
for each group you're trying to say here's the- here's
the work that we expect to get done in this, uh-
So you're aligning the rhythms of the- of
the small number of [OVERLAPPING] I call it rhythms.
Cadence. Yeah. [OVERLAPPING]
Um, you're trying to find like what people- here's what suppose to expect and,
and you're trying to be, um,
at Mozilla we were bigger but if we had different groups
in- in so kind of bigger we have these quarterly goals,
and we had some groups like IT Operation Technology who in a quarter they
would do like basically exactly one-ninetieth of the work every day of the 90 days.
And you had groups, uh,
like the innovation group who would do approximately 0% of the work for
like the first 88, 88 days [LAUGHTER].
And then they would like pull like
all-nighters for a week and get them all down at the end.
And when you're trying to teach is like, um-
You can't do that.
Tha- that's okay. Yeah, you're trying to teach about heterogeneous things as long,
you, you, uh, [NOISE] as long as you agree on commitments.
Right.
And so I think that you're trying to layer these on lightly to
start with and you get heavier weight processes over time but like,
you know, my first startup is like a team league,
we just sent our mail on Friday say,
"Hey, here are the four things that our teams doing next week.
Here the four things that we said we were gonna
do and here's what did we did them or not."
Okay.
And here are the four things we need help on.
[NOISE] And that's a super simple like lightweight email and the 25 people,
and, like call it in five groups.
You still see all of it.
[NOISE].
So let's assume that this start up has grown from 25 to a 100.
Yeah.
So which of these things becomes kind of important then?
Do you- do you spend time on aligning or is it about real-time feedback?
Yeah. Well, [OVERLAPPING].
On you team or?
Right. So I think real-time that's always important,
and I think that in contrast to help people think that
performance management done which is like every annual [NOISE].
I find basically counterproductive.
So you already forgotten- by December you've forgotten what happened in
February and it's- everybody thinks they're above average but they aren't.
[LAUGHTER] The were eligible like, we're like [inaudible] problem.
And, um, so I think that by time it's about a 100 you start,
um, [NOISE] So he's continued from San Antonio,
Texas, I was there last week and with Haskell there.
Ah.
Um, uh, but by the time you get to
a 100 people it's likely that these lightweight processes have turned heavy.
And so I think that in a lot of ways the founder,
what the founder has the moral authority to deal
just run around and like short-circuit thing.
Ah.
And so you say, "Oh, well,
IT is not going to talk to marketing
until marketing gets their goals," and asked them in order,
and you're like, well, this is stupid.
[NOISE] You just run people who got and piano together.
So I find that founders start to hack things and you start to ask questions like,
does this process really represent what we're trying to do?
So I think that hacking and reinvention is the most important thing.
Even at 100.
Yeah. Yeah.
So uh-
A lot of people with a big [OVERLAPPING] social [OVERLAPPING].
So well there's- there's two things,
um, implied in that.
The first one is that,
is that the CEO and actually the senior teams job needs to
evolve because the- they gotta start
delegating stuff and I'm just went through this at Mozilla.
You have to Mozilla 12 people.
Yeah.
And you're left with 500.
So number like that?
Yeah.
So you had- you had to go through this personally to
figure out like couldn't be everywhere at once towards the end.
Yeah.
So ho- how would you figure out when to- when to,
which stuff to keep doing and and which stuff to let go?
Yeah.
So I think Jack Wiener who runs maintain facts the most
about aligning and how you align cultures and- and what, uh,
what you, uh, what I mean when I
say aligning is that you're trying to make sure that if meetings
happen without you that roughly the same thing happens while you're in it [LAUGHTER].
And so I think it's pretty good.
And a lo- and a lot of ways what that means is you just have to spend time together.
And so, uh, I think almost every, uh,
teams that I know at the senior staff meeting once a
week where they just spend time it's like, relatively unstructured.
Yeah. I think Apple spends all day Mondays
together looking at everything across the business.
Um, you know, either doing skip level meetings
where every couple of weeks we'd have me and meeting with all the directors and VPs,
and I'd be trying to model behavior,
and [inaudible] and model our stuff, um.
Now, I remember talking to you once and- and you were worried that,
uh, people didn't feel safe having constructive arguments.
So you said that you were actually holding
constructive arguments in- in- in the hallway so people can see that it was okay.
Yeah. That was kind of amazing.
Yeah. What you're trying to do is, um,
I think that the best managers are specific
and explicit and candid and non-judgmental by knowledge.
So I think you're trying to say that the only thing I really penalize
the Mozilla was if people were hiding the ball. So if somebody-
Okay.
So you say, well, what do you need help with?
If you said, we got it.
Like, that would always be a science are asking lots of questions like,
it really make sure you have it like, the more,
the wobbly they are the more you want to go all the way down.
Can I just include we have some interesting questions from our viewers.
Oh, good.
[OVERLAPPING] we kinda see.
Uh, that sounds fun.
So one of the colleagues here Gamma,
I think says, I run a business that employs starting people.
Uh, we have built a particular culture
but it's resulted in the culture that I don't particularly like [LAUGHTER] and-
Um, when is the right time to work on the company culture?
Is it in the aligning of the organization?
How does one change culture?
Which of the elements of the wheel would you intervene?
Yeah. That's, um [OVERLAPPING].
Yeah, it's interesting.
I think that, yeah,
[inaudible] Um, he had this phrase.
He said, "You need to build a house you want to live in."
And, what- what he meant by that is this,
it was like, you need to build a company you wanna work at. [OVERLAPPING].
That's right.
And so, if you build a company that you think you're supposed to because like you think
the G- the Stanford GSP things [OVERLAPPING] studies says could have it this
way [OVERLAPPING] or you're trying to maximize shareholder value,
or, you know, be a very traversing an Uber.
Like when, like if you build the company you think you're
supposed to build almost always you end up with this thing that,
doesn't qui-quite look like you,
[inaudible] and so I think it's- it's important all along to say,
well, here's- here's what I'm trying to do,
and here's where I think the Deltas are.
When I say culture, um,
I think a lot of people think it means,
like, [NOISE] you know,
what snacks we have, and [OVERLAPPING] where do you go for dinner,
and like how long- how long are lunches and stuff,
what kind of T-shirts do you wear.
Um, when I say culture,
I mean it's how you make decisions and what you celebrate,
what- what you- what you,
[NOISE] , what you reward and what you penalize and,
um, [NOISE] I think it has to be constant.
So I think you have to build channels to- to the whole company, so that every week,
every day, you'll say, "Oh, look at,
um, [NOISE] look at Sherry, who did this thing.
This is amazing, helps the company." Um, no.
You're- you're being defensive about this.
So I'm gonna ask you a whole bunch of questions,
they gonna make you feel like- like you don't want to be defensive again.
[OVERLAPPING] This is a- the- the way we describe it,
[inaudible] , is that, ah,
we ask what's sacred and tabooed and we- and we look to see if- if they, um,
actually have something th- that fits their business,
and then, we- we also look for agreement not to use the name of a company,
by using the name of a company right after my book came out in 2014,
we were sitting around a table with the eight top people
in engineering at Twitter and so [inaudible] can I with you?
Just ask the question I said so what's sacred and what's taboo?
They couldn't answer the question.
Each person said, "Well,
I can tell you about my last company, Salesforce, Apple whatever."
But they actually didn't know what was sacred and
taboo Twitter and that's not a good side.
Yeah, I think this brings up the other point which is I think
most companies slide through these things and they don't make I- it.
So, number one they feel like culture is fixed-
Right.
-so they don't explicitly change it.
The other is that they change it little bit [OVERLAPPING] at a time,
and when I found as you grew [inaudible] I couldn't change my message every day.
I need it to be a sa- same message until there was a change,
and then they say everybody were changing now [OVERLAPPING] here's a big break,
and we just went through this with one of the companies I work with,
um, where they started with the four core values,
and one of them is kindness, for example, and look,
e-either you find a seller who [inaudible] um,
and I try to remember it in my own life but the, um,
it wasn't working for us as a corporate [OVERLAPPING] value,
and so uh, she actually just went rewrote it and so he said, okay,
we're gonna- we're gonna go and redo this,
and we're gonna acknowledge that it's- it's change and like sign-up,
resign-up [OVERLAPPING] or, or,
or move on, and that's okay.
That's on- one of my favorite examples so that is somewhere
under the end of his tenure Andy Grove of Intel fame.
He took having fun off the badges,
because he said that's disingenuous we do all sorts of things that aren't fun,
and we're gonna ask you to do things that aren't fun to succeeded.
I think we should be honest about it [OVERLAPPING] those are
my kind of favorite examples o- of ah see all,
tell them the truth and,
and uh, and having a good reason for it.
Yeah. [OVERLAPPING].
So I wanna go back to some of the questions and so there's
an interest in how do you stress-test some of these elements on the wheel?
[NOISE] so, can mean stress-test alignment or firing people,
like how do you know your alignment is working?
How do you know you're firing the right kind of people?
Uh, I mean is that a stress-test that you'd recommend?
I think that's the question readers are contemplating.
Yeah [inaudible] you guys have a point of view on this.
I think that, with the,
[NOISE] like you always have to bring it back
to what's the organisa- why does the organization exist?
[OVERLAPPING] and what are you trying to do?
[OVERLAPPING] and like the truth is like all you really have as proxy metrics it's-
it's hard to say why we want revenue to be high this
quarter and every employee to figure how to do that,
and so you got a revenue you might-might associate with user metrics or, um,
hiring metrics or whatever,
and so I think you've gotta figure out like,
like what we imagine ourselves
against [OVERLAPPING] how do we tell whether we're getting better or worse.
And a lot of times I think yo- you make- you're
practicing making commitments to each other and making,
making [inaudible] and being honest do you make the climates or not.
So let me turn the question another way around.
Maybe can we think of stress-tests as,
um, a question of the aliens.
So in any organization,
you have average quality or the mean and the variance. [OVERLAPPING].
Yeah.
Now when, when would you recommend that er
you know is high-variance good or is it bad or put another way?
Values great to find people?
How do you go about firing people?
[OVERLAPPING] You need to do that quickly in a startup or like you need to [OVERLAPPING].
So, so just, th- this is something I talk about a lot,
you know I- I always think of the Netflix versus [inaudible].
So Patty McCord, the Netflix no performance improvement plan.
They walk and you're gone and I-I I had a
[inaudible] He basically describe firing 80 out of- about 80 out of 120 people and he said,
"I loved them, they just didn't fit anymore."
and yeah, and then there is a [inaudible] when we interviewed ED, we said Ed.
So what do you do with non-performance [inaudible] ,
I used to fire him quick but now when I do,
when I did that it would create fear,
but now what I do is I wait for everybody to tell me that that person sucks,
[OVERLAPPING] and then when I fire them there's no fear.
So he said I've learned to wait longer,
and that was th- that was one of the only,
maybe the only person agonized completely so [inaudible] ,
we gonna say if we wanna talk about firing directors in particular.
Yeah.
Um, but still there's,
mean that's still completely different philosophies. [OVERLAPPING]
Very welcome. Very welcome
Yeah, I think- what's I think Ed is a very smart guy.
So I think [inaudible] says something like you should, you should [NOISE].
Sees things differently [LAUGHTER].
I think also that the [inaudible] will be [APPLAUSE] I think
either is fine as long as you understand what
your philosophy is and look and you are exposed about it and intentional about it.
So, what I mean is that [NOISE] I kind of view,
you may hire a person,
th-then coming to work for your company is like you're making a two-sided [inaudible].
So the person is committed to work for your company [OVERLAPPING] the company
is committing to do some set of things to have that person be successful.
Um.
This is how I think about.
What that means is that there's a burden on you,
you know, so it's a hard decision,
and once you do that there's some obligation you have to do,
to do what you said. So [OVERLAPPING].
That's back to the mindset.
Yeah.
There's agreements that helps.
Yeah, I think there's other ways to do that,
but that [inaudible] you know,
that will tend to mean that you tend to,
you're trying to understand what the context is,
another person's feeling and then you try to say,
well here's the gap,
can we talk together about how to close the gap in some time-box.
Right? That's how I do it.
Um, which is kinda in the middle between
far fast and like letter by tell me [OVERLAPPING] -
Yeah. I wanna push you.
-am not a little passive by the way,
so I find it, so like he's doing it,
because empirically he's realized that it's it's net positive [inaudible] I tell them it's bad.
I find that a little bit,
passive management almost never,
in my experience very good. That's interesting.
Let me push all of us in this a little bit.
I'm kinda wondering, is it a matter of
personal philosophy or does it largely have a lot to do with,
what the business is all about?
So when I think of Ed and Pixar,
it's a creative business.
Very long-term time [OVERLAPPING].
Long-term time horizon, where risk taking is important.
I'm wondering, maybe the reason it delays firing is,
he doesn't want fear to chill risk-taking.
On the other hand when I look at some of the companies you advised.
There the task is a little different,
often it's a new product development task.
And in any as you would know better than I would,
in any new product development task,
it's the weakest link or dictates the pace of new product development.
And so it doesn't actually have to deal with,
how the task difference between,
new product development and creativity-
Yeah. I think you know that that is for sure
true [OVERLAPPING] because even, even inside as,
a small company you have different firing patterns across different [inaudible].
So sales is very numeric.
Engineers [inaudible] pay commission
where they make so much money and like the truth is like because if they missed
a number they're fired [OVERLAPPING]
paint patterns look like this all the time where things are your houses look like that,
but I think that different type functions, in different outcome.
If anything it's important to be intentional it say,
this is a commitment we're making rightfully [OVERLAPPING] employees making to us.
Right. So uh-
When this engagement become an issue?
When you become 50,000 or when you become 5,000 or 500 or,
uh, you know, can you give us, a- um,
you know, when does reinvention become the top priority?
Yeah. We having question was more like when,
when does disengagement happened and when
disengagement starts, starts to hurt the company?
Um.
[NOISE] But I think that, um, I don't know.
The most interesting companies that ever rise pretty engaged,
um, do think that- he mentioned Hewlett and Packard,
uh, which is kind of ancient history now,
but the Packard used to talk about management by walking around-
Right.
-BWA. He would, he would just walk around and
he'd sit at an engineers desk to get to know what you're doing.
And my sense is that that's a- that was a very,
very effective way of managing,
and I think if it's connecting and connected it's-
it strips away that organization chart like I saw.
Yeah. You guys know that I, my- my, you know,
CEO Mozilla, I had a standing desk that was based in the middle hallway.
But I- and I put it there because I
wanted to make sure that as people were walking back and forth,
like, we always made eye contact.
If you make eye contact, that means you almost always have to talk.
And so, that was one way of just encouraging people to
talk and say hello to e- even somebody who might be in a different order,
three levels up, or whatever.
Right. Right. So, again,
I'm keeping track of time here.
Um, so the- um,
some months ago, I invited this executive from Uber.
You know, Bob and I wrote a case study,
of course, on Uber and Thuan Pham.
Thuan Pham. Okay. CTO.
But this was a different executive?
And he had worked in Uber for- so I asked him,
I said, "Hey, how long have you worked in Uber?"
And he said I worked there for four years.
And I said four years and he laughed to me said,
"I know it's four years,
but for me it feels like I've worked in 16 different companies."
Each quarter was a different company.
Was he sort of exaggerating or was he- or is
this how fast companies change as they scale?
Yeah. I think Uber is a very special case because
it- because of that just massive ambition and massive growth trajectory.
[NOISE] But even if, um,
companies are involved with [inaudible] organizations of prototypes,
so we just pulled our organization last week
[NOISE] where we changed some things and said,
look, this is an eight-week prototype.
And I feel like it's- it's framing at upper people like oh,
well, these are not my report.
This is not my or- this is- this is
a- an experiment that we're going to have [NOISE] to see how work gets done.
And if some- we're trying to create
some dis- disassociation with the organizational structure itself.
I do find that people get really locked in to org structures.
As they're in like here my report,
here's my org.
My one-on-ones.
And I try to break that everywhere I can because I feel like,
you know, the facts on the ground,
facts inside the company, they don't change. They're being changed rapidly.
And so there's some things you want to get locked in.
You want to get the sales execution engine going.
I kept the QA engine going.
[NOISE] I think for a lot of things where your- the terrain is unknown,
you're not sure you have the right org.
So, so, so that's- so dig into that a little bit, uh,
um, one of the things that we look for it- it's basically habit.
So you, you start using SOPs to do
the exact same thing and that's great when you're doing the right thing.
Yup.
But when you're doing the, the, what is it?
The wrong thing the right way and you can go down really quick.
Yup.
Uh, any red flags you look for that people are just
doing what they've always done because they've always done it and you gotta,
you gotta put the brakes?
Yes. So that the- the, I mean,
the red flag is when you get people not asking questions.
Silence is like ohm.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER].
The, um, so what I- the very early days of data science in
2005 and we bought it- somebody
before it's called data science into Mozilla which is we had like,
you know, 100 million users on which you couldn't tell what's happening at the user-base.
So Robert Diaz, the data scientist who worked for
Steve Levitt on Freakonomics [NOISE] in- and,
um, so he just started generating reports and
I had him send it to me every night at seven o'clock.
And my executive team didn't like this very much because here I was,
just got home, having dinner and they would see this [OVERLAPPING] report.
They'd see this report coming through and like at 7:03 like there'll be
me responding like why is
this one like this and marked down in Germany and why is this like this.
And I was trying to teach people like every time,
every day, look at things and say,
"Oh, why does it look like this? What's happening?"
No. That's true. Question.
Yeah. People didn't love it because they,
they felt like they had to answer the questions.
But it got better over time.
They started asking questions.
And send out, send out three or send out two before acting.
Yeah. I want to sort of step in here and invite our viewers to send more questions.
Yes.
We got about 10,15 minutes more.
I'm going to sort of pick a couple of questions but please add them.
These questions are gifts for us, so don't forget that.
So one lovely question that somebody, ah,
put up, I think it was a little bit before, was titles.
Yeah, our titles a thing, um,
see you ought to think about or [OVERLAPPING] of the sops to people?
Like what, what are they, I mean?
Yeah. I, um, I'm curious what the research doesn't ask like the,
ah, I pro- I struggle with this.
Sometimes I think about files as free gifts.
I get out early in the early days. I think as the organization gets bigger,
they become quite expensive.
Usually, they imply things about how- what the organization looks like.
Um, [NOISE] you know, a lot of- a lot of
companies today will- don't want to hire directors
or VPs and they'll still call everybody a head-up or
something to indicate leadership and ownership.
Um, [NOISE] I- I think this is a challenging question.
I don't- I don't really have a good answer, too.
I think that you should be clear about who's on your executive team.
That you should be clear about ownership and
I need- to the extent you can't be usually clear about,
um, [NOISE] ah, compensation progression.
Right.
So having five or six levels, you will progress through.
A [inaudible] levels almost always should be the force between titles.
Right.
Yes. [NOISE]
But- [NOISE] [inaudible] This is quite right. Extending them
to where the decision rights are unclear.
What- what that leads to is a bunch of dysfunctional conflict where people act
like cats scratching for, um, to the top.
So, uh, I think that's the most important thing.
I think the [inaudible] idea is to-
To idealize the direct responsible individuals and say this is
the person responsible for this set of decisions.
I guess the clearest, crispest way to do it,
it sometimes means that things fall in the cracks.
Did you do a weird study on titles?
Yeah. We actually did a mischievous study on titles where
what we did was in this experiment with 82 new venture teams,
in the treatment condition, we asked, ah,
all the teams in both conditions with four-person teams,
they had to build a prototype.
We had to get an external panel of judges to evaluate the prototype.
But in the treatment condition,
all that we asked was,
we asked people and said come up with a job title
that showcases your unique person on the spot.
So- and it was extraordinary.
People came up with titles like guru of cybersecurity,
defender of the source code,
chief shmoozer, [LAUGHTER] chief banana, chief instigator.
And we were kind of quite surprised that at the end of the experiment,
teams where people chose their own job titles,
they actually built a prototype faster.
But most importantly, the prototypes they built, they, at least,
in the eyes of an external panel of judges were measurably
superior to the prototype's prepared by the,
uh, other teams under controlled conditions.
What?
So my sort of speculation is the um- and we actually had evidence of this,
when you ask people to choose their own job titles,
the first thing is you're actually triggering a sense of ownership.
Right.
You chose the title.
[OVERLAPPING] The- the other equally vital thing
was in the teams where people chose their own job titles,
it was made clear who should do what.
There was no confusion about the division of labor.
So, you know, uh, people were specialists in an area.
You kinda went to them. They were supposed to do that.
You know, there wasn't like hey, this is my issue.
This is not my issue.
I'm not, you know, et cetera.
So knowledge utilization actually unfolded far more efficiently in such teams.
And in teams where everybody had like cookie cutter titles, it was kinda opaque.
You just didn't know who was good at what.
Yup. That makes sense here.
So problems-
Because to say that's not my job or not my area,
that's the biggest road block to the organization's structure.
I mean across everything,
I think that's the number one thing is like,
oh, that's not my job.
Right. Uh, any other question that,
ah, strikes your fancy, Bob?
Ah, John-
Uh, somebody asked about how you build culture in remote work forces which I think is,
is an important question,
I think, we're seeing in Silicon Valley.
Yes.
People are- people have moved. We're- we're starting development centers everywhere.
Um, Mozilla was a big distributed workforce because people everywhere,
kinda 30 different countries on the world.
Even though they're for 500 people and, um, [NOISE] Yeah.
I think it's- it's just like anything else.
You have to decide like how you're gonna communicate through- and you have to test,
test the fidelity of communications, that's engagement.
I think you also just have to, um,
figure out ways to get people to be in-person together often.
So like the rule I made in Mozilla was- we had enough money where I said, um-
Anytime you need to get together to work on telling somebody, fly somewhere.
And I don't care where it is,
just figure out where to be and where it would work for a week and just be there,
and I'll scream if it gets too expensive.
But I never, I never complained about it.
So, very minor thing for those of you interested in the question
of virtual teams that are geographically dispersed.
Our wonderful colleague, Pam Hinds in the School of Engineering,
has actually done very interesting research in
that area and if I recall her findings, um,
this goes back to your point again, John,
what she found was the two things that if
you've been watched these things geographically dispersed teams could become subcultures.
Yet in Shanghai, I'm in San Francisco and then you kind of fight about everything.
The two things that they, you know,
work with Mark Martinson that they found were very valuable to deal with
dispersion was amazingly the frequency of communication the [OVERLAPPING].
Mostly face to face,
face to face early in the relationship.
And it's actually frequent spontaneous communication
as opposed to prescribe communication.
And the other thing was what they found was that
this spontaneous communication actually showed up her sense of shared identity.
Are we taking it as to be multi-modal.
So, ah, Mozilla use IRC which is sort of it some [inaudible] slack.
I have mixed feelings about slack,
and the slack is very productive in many ways and kind of reference other ways but
we use sort of a slack stock vacation thing by [inaudible] tweet to a lot of employment videos,
but also in the kitchens like we had open
Skype or Hangout conversations that were
between Mountain View and Toronto and just open all the time.
So, if you're going to a coffee in the afternoon, it's pronto,
you can see someone getting coffee in the kitchen [OVERLAPPING]
That's really interesting [OVERLAPPING].
Spontaneous interactions people who are random.
And I think the other thing is like monkeying with
like desk and desk and furniture layouts pretty often.
So, you started to move things around.
So, just, just on,
um, on slack, ah.
So [inaudible] and I, you know,
project on organizational friction
and at least our take at this point my technicians speak for
you is that slack can be good or maybe not so good but it's a platform, It's okay.
Where the problem occurs is when you start getting
platform overload and literally you can sit and watch- my daughter has a job like this,
she's using about eight different platforms at once.
She's using Slack, she's, she's using, um,
email, she is using sales force,
and that's just some of them, I can go on and on.
And when you start just having this overload
and being able to sort of keep track of where everything is,
it really, ah, makes it hard for people to,
to do their work no matter how skilled they are.
So, so, to me that's the bigger problem.
It's sort of the tragedy of the commons and maybe each one might be a
little bit better but then it destroys sort of the whole.
You see how many screens that,
that you'll see where she works.
How many screens people have open on their little laptop is just amazing.
I suspect this is a transitionary problem.
I suspect like my,
[NOISE] you know my 13-year-old son would be
playing Fortnite and watching Fortnite and doing a face-time,
doing all these things at the same time and texting.
So, my sense is that,
this is, it just,
it feels awkward to ask because we have
all our brains like one thing on the screen at a time.
Um, but I do think always backward are kind of different things,
like I think that the expectations and norms like you so he texts me,
I kind of expect them to texted my [inaudible].
He calls I think slack has
different excitations which is whoever is around answer question could or right away.
There's different norms that get built up for a variety of reasons.
They- these are all different media.
But when you have too many,
it gets when you're trying to be your job it can get [OVERLAPPING].
Yeah, I think that it's [inaudible].
Okay. All right. Much as we'd like to spend more time.
We're nearing, [inaudible] Do you have any partying talks for our viewers John?
I think my sense would be that what we do in the GSB class we teach,
as we say, two things more than anything else like the active,
you know, all these processes and the intentional about them.
And so, understand what you're trying to build and
don't ever sort of lean back and wait for,
wait for things to happen, like be more active.
But, but one thing I would add which comes up in our work all sorts of ways is, ah,
have somebody in your life who you trust and cares about you,
who can tell you when thi- when you're screwing up, ah,
there's lots of people don't tell you you're screwing up you might not
trust but those are the most valuable people.
And, and if you look at research on, on, ah,
self-awareness so the worst person to ask whether they're confident,
whether they're jerk is that person
themselves and the best person to ask are people who know them and care about them.
Yeah. Very well put.
If I can just add, ah, you know,
ah, my own quick contribution,
I'd like to swiftly underline what,
ah, John mentioned which is,
don't sleep walk your way to a culture.
[LAUGHTER] make sure you actually actively design it and that's the outcome of,
you know, choice, ah, so to speak.
And, ah, I think, ah,
the other interesting so the bookend is, ah, ah,
what Bob sort of mentioned is also very vital and that is as a startup scales,
and to John's point there's a lot of reinvention,
when there's a lot of reinvention if you're a CEO or if you're the founder,
you're often leading from a position of not knowing.
And when you lead from a position of not knowing,
for some of us that engender anxiety,
and if you only get in touch with your feelings of anxiety,
you're bound to classify more things in the environment as threats than as opportunities.
But if on the other hand you pursue Bob's advise and get feedback from trusted people,
you're able to move from the door called doubt and uncertainty,
hopefully, to a room called confidence.
And that in turn might allow the person more [OVERLAPPING].
[inaudible] um, comment because whenever I started having an anxiety,
Tacky, looks at me and he says, "Bob,
let's just think of it as an adventure even
though things are all screwed up and you're messed up,
it's amazing and you cannot just see it now no matter how things are screwed up,
we just keeps-" he thinks it's fun.
And I've sort of learned to kind of go along,
you're going to think it's actually a great model in
you're good about learning from mistakes and stuff but you just how this is really cool.
I think work. [LAUGHTER]
Sorry, we, we all do make a mistake.
So, keep those two things in mind as you're building a culture.
And in fact, in many ways John's comments and Bob's comments a wonderful bookends.
You deliberately need to design culture on the one hand.
But on the other to Bob's point,
you really need to underline how you manage,
how you lead when you don't know.
And to Bob's point again,
when you don't know you can't afford to be a hippopotamus.
You'd better be an elephant.
When you look at a hippopotamus,
the hippopotamus is the biggest part of the hippos face of course is the mouth.
And when you lead, when you know we use the mouth
often but hopefully when you don't know you become an elephant,
you use your ears and leave them there.
[LAUGHTER] So, [LAUGHTER] good luck on your elephant
[OVERLAPPING] elephant time adventures.
Thank you all so very much for your time.
Thank you [OVERLAPPING] And thank you John for [inaudible].
Yeah, thank you. Thank you to today's speakers and to all of you for attending.
If you enjoyed our webinar today you might also be interested in some of these courses,
um, I hope to see you all next time. Thank you.
Thank you.